- That's legal.
I can actually come across
and just whack you as hard as I can.
You can knock a guy out.
(speaks in foreign language)
My name is Konishki
and I am ex-sumotori.
I've been in Japan for the past 40 years.
I joined Sumo 1982,
so I've been in the circuit for 16 years
as a professional sumotori.
Today, we'll be looking at
some sumo scenes from movies
and see how real it is to
my eyes, Konishki'e eyes.
- That man is Mainoumi, the
greatest fighter in Japan
- [Woman] But he's so tiny.
- It's very real.
His name is Mainoumi.
He's actually a real
professional sumotori.
That's the thing that a lot of Americans
or a lot of foreigners don't know.
The professional Sumo
League, our professional,
which is only one in the world,
we don't have any weight class.
It's not wrestling it's,
it's you just translating
the word into sumo wrestling
where we call sumotori
but we don't even call it a sport.
It's more like a culture.
- Hatakikomi is a movement
smaller combatant uses to throw
the larger man off-balance.
- So like how the actor explained,
he's going to use a hatakikomi,
which is a technique used
by a smaller sumotori.
We have like different techniques in sumo
and the reason for that is
because it's taken advantage
by the smaller guys.
The bigger guys is
about strength and power
and then how you move
your weight and stuff.
But the smaller guys that are tricky,
it's like they kick your
feet, they pull your hands,
they twist your elbows
and it's very dangerous.
And salt is used very much
in the Japanese culture.
If you go through many
shrines or temples in Japan,
you are gonna notice that
there's certain places
they put salt just to purify.
And there's a thing in
the Japanese culture,
when you go to someone's funeral,
when you go back they
give you these envelopes,
there's salt in it.
So what it does is chase away bad spirits
before you walk into your home.
And sumotoris use the salt
to actually bless their
rings every single day
- [Man] Look, there.
- The hair you see during that tournament
they call it "oicho."
Oicho is for only high rankers.
What we regularly wear is what
you see the samurai movies
like "Chonmage."
If you go bald,
I notice they're doing extensions.
This is why you can separate the sumotori
from any other professional sport
because we have to dress like them.
You're not allowed to wear any of these.
You get caught wearing something else,
they probably kick you out right away.
So you have to walk the
streets with kimonos
during the winter
and then yokota, what we call
it, is a lighter material
and we have to wear what
setters are called slippers.
The setters we wear, we
can tell what rank you are
just by looking at the wrap
and from the slippers you wear.
It's a pull down.
This technique is used
by a smaller opponent
because it's all about speed and timing.
But all he's trying to
do is just to beat you
to make you come forward
and push your weight forward fast enough
where he can time it,
where he just throw the
(beep) at you and stuff.
So that take dig itself is well used.
I wouldn't use it because
by the time I do it,
they probably hit my belly
because I'm pulling down.
It's a very winning move
for that type of sumotori.
This is such a cool clip.
The way you see it the dohyo,
which is the sumo ring.
If you look at the way
that it's built those days
they used to have the poles on the corner
to hold up the top.
During my career, we still had that,
not in a major tournament
but between our tours.
The thing I like about the
scene, it makes it so like,
authentic the way they built that stadium.
I would like to see it go back to that
and make it lesser
because right now you got to imagine
we have six major
tournaments a year in Japan
and there's 12,000 people
there, 15 days in a row.
And that is crazy
because they're using two real sumotoris
and this is beautiful.
I think I give them a 10.
I wish I could wrestle that era.
The way it's built around the ring itself
and very authentic.
What you just seen
is exactly what they were
doing in that tournament
or during the match.
They have a thing what
we call, "chirichozu,"
which is they come up
and they do the ceremony
where they slap their
hands and they do all this.
This is another tradition
that for us to respect our opponent
to show him that I left
my double barrel at home.
I ain't going to shoot you,
I'm going to beat you
up with my own hands.
It's that kind of thing.
The referee doesn't say (beep).
He gotta touch all fours.
The hands have to touch.
He uses eye contact
so that's what makes
sumos very unique too.
If you're running a hundred yard dash,
somebody pushed the guns
or even a boxing match,
the bell rings right?
But this is all eye contact.
It's a funny clip.
The motions and everything is kind of real
but the throws are, that wouldn't happen.
They would only happen in a superman move.
Those throwing techniques
that you're going to see
some guys get flip flipped,
like, back flipped like, you know.
That can really happen.
The word for what technique
they used, kimarite,
means is today's match
kimarite, is he forced out.
Kimarite is just the meaning of that.
That is very real.
One of these two guys are
supposed to be a grand champion.
If you're grand champion,
you get (beep) kicked.
So people would actually
throw the zabutons.
It's those pillows that they
sit on at the tournaments
and you see this even till today.
It's tradition.
The people watching on the
side on the floor get hurt.
Some people think it's just good luck
even though they go to the
hospital with broken bones.
But because sumotoris are trained so well,
we learn how to break falls.
No one really gets hurt
falling off the ring.
Everything is more like
elbow or twisted knees.
A six or seven, 6.5.
7 is good, it's good.
Very, very good.
The guy who has the fan is
what we call a "yobidashi,"
which is a ring caller.
The other guy who has
the panel in his hand
is called "gyoji," which is the referee.
Every sumo stable has one of each.
Those positions too are ranked.
You have like from the lowest
rank to the highest rank.
The drums would never be there.
But that's the only, only
thing that I wouldn't see
in a regular sumo tournament.
That is very normal.
The shiko is the squatting that they do
where they lift up their legs
and pound their legs down.
That's what they call "shiko."
So that's the sumo squat.
That's what they do to
stomp away the bad spirits
on the ring.
In your first six months,
all you do is shiko.
You do like a thousand a day, easy.
That's the best exercise
to strengthen your legs
and actually strengthen up your core.
But I think because of
the exercises we do,
it help prevents injuries.
It loosen up your hips
and stuff like that.
You can get lower.
(crowd cheering)
This is exactly what you
would see at at a sumo match.
Actually we can go
and actually broke your elbow in one move.
What the guy just did, he can step out
and what we do,
use my elbow to clamp down
on his hand that's on me.
And all after these
twist in and twist down,
I can break his elbow.
So my fingers all broken from that
because we learn how to
cut your hand off the belt
when you grab it.
And there's like four
or five different ways
to kick the belt off your hand.
It's very easy to break your fingers.
That's legal.
I can actually come across
and just whack you as hard as I can.
You can knock a guy out
cause it's a karate chop.
The mix of martial arts,
aikido, and karate.
And actually I can brake your nose
with my hand, with my palm,
which I did during my career.
So people don't know that part.
To win a sumo match is simple.
It's 5.5 meters, that round circle.
You have 5.5 meters to work with.
So the object of the game
is to push your opponent out of the ring
or throw him into the ring.
Anything but the bottom of
his feet touches the floor,
you lose the match.
So it sounds easy,
but having guys over 400 pound
going against each other, pushing weight,
they can try to take
advantage of weight shifting
and stuff like that.
It's not as easy as it looks.
I would rate it a nine,
it's just the jumps
that took a point away.
But it's a very good clip.
(speaking in foreign language)
That's the ranking,
since the second highest is the champion.
Before they had grand champion, Yokozuna,
the only the highest rank was
only Ozeki in the olden days.
Never been done by any foreigner, bro.
I'm the first to ever do that
and it's a shocking to the sumo world
or to the country because
no one has done it before
and I was very fortunate
to be in the right time,
right place, right mind,
physical to handle the sport.
(speaking in foreign language)
It's the best protein.
Call it "chankinabe."
That's how they put our weight on.
It's very, very nutritious.
Very, very healthy too.
It can be chicken, can
be pork, it can be beef,
can be a mixture of different meats,
can be fish, seafood.
So that changes every single day.
You don't have the same menu at all.
And you have to be very healthy
because they check on your
body if you're diabetic
or they won't take you.
They check your heart
every like twice a year.
They're very crucial about being healthy
'cause to be big and to grow bigger,
you have to have a healthy body
to handle all the eating too.
(speaking in foreign language)
You got a 10 on that one.
He's actually getting introduced
to a stable that he's gonna join.
You are guest until you
come officially a sumotori.
So he's getting treated as a VIP
which everybody get treated.
If you're not a sumotori
and you're invited to
come to a sumo stable,
get used to it
because they'll be serving
you until you leave.
(speaking in foreign language)
It's a building bro.
Everybody lives there
and everything is in there.
Their practice area is in there.
The shower rooms are huge.
The kitchens are huge.
They actually can make their
sumo stables into restaurants
if they wanted to.
Everybody sleep on futons.
Even that is by ranking too.
So the higher rank have their own room.
I had my own room to sleep in.
But the lower rank, they
all sleep in one room.
So it's real.
What you just saw is exactly what happens.
(upbeat music)
(speaking in foreign language)
- A million percent right.
You have to be the first to get up,
get people's stuff prepared.
You've got to be the last to go to sleep
because you're taking
people's stuff to wash
and you've got to make sure everybody,
your senior guys have their towels,
everything they need for practice
at their futons before you go to sleep.
They make it sound so nice, bro.
I had to wipe floors
from 3:30 in the morning
before I went to sumo school.
For six months I did that.
After sweeping, I'm on my knees
and you're not allowed to like, mops.
It's like you actually use towels.
Clean all the toilets,
take all the garbage out
by 4:30 in the morning
and then I walk to
school every single day.
You can put a 10 for this clip.
It's the real deal.
It's like that's how life is.
- Ah Jesus Christ,
these diaper's making
my nuts rub together.
- The best way to explain it,
sumotoris are like walking lucky charms.
People like to come and touch sumotoris
because it gives them good luck.
So like for pregnant ladies,
they would actually go
to get their belly rubbed by a sumotori
just to have a healthy baby.
(speaking in foreign language)
They wouldn't even allow his socks on.
The mawashi is the sumo belt
and everybody has their own colors.
For their top ranks,
they get to pick what silk
color they want to wrestle in.
This is called "sagari."
If you go to the Shinto, you
go to any temple or any shrines
and if you look on the top,
there's this actually
straws that had been weaved
and that's what the yokozuna would wear
and you see stuff sticking out.
So that kind of represent
like a god, a tori,
which is a Shinto temple.
(crowd cheering)
That's even impossible
to grab, the middle.
The silk is so hard, like it's like a cup.
There's no way you can grab that stuff.
That's why there's nothing
really real about it.
They built the arena
like the arenas would look
like outside of Tokyo.
All the bleachers, all the stands.
Beacause Tokyo we have our own stadium.
It's owned by the Sumo Association.
But all the other like Osaka in March,
they have July in a place called Nagoya.
I give them two for trying.
(soft music)
- When the harmony comes from within,
the balance will come by itself.
(speaking in foreign language)
- The only good thing about
this whole clip is "shingitai,"
it's the word that we use a lot.
The spirit and of sumo.
And when they plan to make you
a high ranker or something,
there're always the judges that judge us,
would actually judge
us on that, shingitai.
What she's trying to explain to the girl
is how to get that spirit and stuff,
but you don't really need
that to do the squat.
She's doing it wrong yourself too so.
If you look at a real
good squat as a sumotori,
you notice they're going
straight up and down.
The knee is not even
coming forward and stuff.
You have to transfer all your weight
to one side of your body,
extend the knee that all your weight is on
and then lift your leg.
Not easy to do, everybody's
just lifting up your leg.
That's not the exercise.
They do have sumo women, sumo
wrestlers in amateur level
and it's huge, is a huge
sport in amateur level.
The heavy weight ones are
actually from Japan and stuff, so.
It's still prohibited.
In professional sumo it is.
They're not allowed to even
step on our rings, that's right.
Even our practice rings,
they're not allowed.
Ladies are not allowed onto the rings.
Oh, maybe a five, four.
You can see she's trying to scold her
so I give them that much.
(upbeat music)
It's like the conditioning part of sumo
which is what we call, "butsukari keiko."
It was one of the hardest exercises.
One guy catches all the hits
and what he does, see him
pulling the head down,
that is to try to see,
get your opponent as tight as he can
and see if he can keep his balance.
When we used to do this, we
weren't allowed to show anybody.
The boss would actually
kick all the media out.
That's how hardcore it was.
So what you see is exactly what we do.
When you renew the ring,
they do a blessing.
And this is done every single tournament.
Every major tournament,
right before they start, they
get what they call "ika,"
dry squid,
and they have sake
and they have, I think, rice, and salt.
In the middle of the ring,
there's a hole in it that
they put all that in there
and they cover it up
before every tournament.
So it's very ceremonial.
Give it a 10, this is a good one.
Oh this is Kitao, good acting.
But that guy is a real grand champion.
So I don't think.
If it was real, this guy
would've get his (beep) kicked.
He's a 6'7", 430 pounds sumotori.
We are same age.
We wrestle against each other a lot
because his background is judo.
So depending on how your body is built,
there's techniques that you can use.
For me, I'm round and big and heavy
so my idea of finishing a match,
I have to finish within five seconds.
That's my goal.
It's illegal to punch in sumo.
So this is not even a sumo match.
It has no comparison.
It's just another WWE.
The other rule that people don't know
it's like when you grab
the hair by accident,
if you touch the hair you lose the match.
And the other thing,
if your belt get loose
and the judges around this,
five judges around the ring
can see your jingle bells
or your marbles hanging
out, you lose your match.
You can actually chop his jaw.
You can actually broke the nose.
There's a lot of guys who got K.O'd
right in the middle of the
rink because of the chop.
Zero.
Something like this would never happen.
My favorite clip was
"Sumo Do, Sumo Don't."
The actor's getting Butsukari Keiko.
It reminds me of the little
villages in Japan still today.
They love sumo so much they go out
and teach as much as they know
to the younger kids and stuff.
If you enjoyed this video guys,
you better click, click, click
or I'm gonna come and sumo stump you.
Keep on stumping.
Sumo style.